hello everyone so i'd like to make a
disclaimer before we get into the video
i do not condone the harassment of this
person please do not go find them or
message them or bully them do not stoop
to this person's level thank you let's
get into it so last week i uploaded a
video called gideon off near is the
villain where it was doing relatively
well getting over a hundred thousand
views within the first day i had around
6 000 subscribers at the time and a
video doing that well was a really big
deal to me and still very much is after
the video was uploaded i was getting
some comments that said that i was a
sham and that i plagiarized the entire
video off of somebody else i was a
little confused because i wrote my own
script i used all my own recorded clips
and edited the entire video myself so
like all weird comments like that where
they provide no constructive criticism
whatsoever and just seemingly saying
something that is not true they're just
deleted by myself or my moderators just
so it doesn't confuse the people who
actually want to comment feedback on the
video that is a practice that most
youtubers and content creators use i was
then messaged on twitter by several
people posting a link to an elden ring
subreddit thread called agt jake
plagiarizes to make his videos which was
created by someone with the username and
caligon v obviously i was very confused
and wanted to see what was going on this
thread was claiming that i plagiarized
this person's elden ring lore theory
word for word into my own video while
this is not true and i wrote my own
script for the entire video i was
inspired to make the video off of a
theory that i had heard on the elden
ring subreddit what i failed to do in my
original upload of this video was credit
the place that i had heard this theory i
dm'd in caligon on reddit twitter and
discord apologizing and asking what i
can do to make right of this situation
for hours he never answered my dms and
would only talk to me in his open reddit
thread i even tried replying to him on
this open reddit thread where my
comments would be immediately downvoted
and ignored needless to say i felt
terrible i should have 100 percent
credited the source where i first heard
the theory but the claim for plagiarism
i thought at the time was just because
he was frustrated with the situation and
i felt horrible because this was an
ethical issue that i wanted to make
right so i took down the video and
re-uploaded it with a two-minute intro
where i apologize for not citing my
source correctly and gave credit to the
user who made the reddit theory post
what i was confused about was that the
reddit post i heard the theory from
was made by someone with the name of
practical meat but the person who made
the agtj plagiarizes his videos thread
was and caligun v i didn't really know
how reddit works with that because the
theory was over a month old
and maybe he changed his name but the
original post would still have his old
name i'm not sure but i gave proper
credit to practical meat and re-uploaded
the video as the night went on i was
getting spammed with messages on all of
my youtube videos my twitter dms and the
reddit thread was starting to get some
major traction i thought i did the right
thing couldn't do anything more and just
went to bed when i woke up the next
morning i saw that the reddit thread had
been taken down by moderators for
harassment flaming baiting ranting
discrediting and bad mouthing looking at
the comments of the thread it seemed
like people were getting pretty personal
about the situation and it was taken
down for that i had been getting death
threats in my dms so i was happy to see
this get taken down obviously so i just
blocked all the people spreading hate
and was just ready to move on the next
day i found out that my video had been
taken down due to copyright infringement
and a copyright strike had been added to
my channel looking into it the person
who filed the copyright claim was ann
caligan v for plagiarizing his elden
ring lore theory that he posted to
reddit it was at this point i saw what
in caligan was claiming copyright
ownership of it wasn't the lore theory
by practical meat but a comment in
caligan made to the lore theory a
comment that i was never aware existed
when i originally read his plagiarism
thread i assumed he was practical meat
and that he meant a large chunk of my
video was verbatim what he had said in
his theory but no he was talking about a
comment he had made to it and at that
point i realized who i was dealing with
here practical meat had nothing to do
with this situation it's all in caligan
v claiming copyright ownership over a
comment he made on an elden ring
subreddit lore theory i think claiming
the rights to a fan theory
on a video game where everyone is
theorizing the same item descriptions
dialogue and mostly environmental
storytelling is asinine it's all based
on an idea of in-game lore that this
person is trying to copyright claim
while i did not plagiarize this person's
comment word for word even i was taken
back by how similar it was to my own
script while there were differences in
it it had the same breakdown of what we
were both trying to explain due to it
being a theory that has been discussed
by many content creators in the elden
ring community on youtube twitter and
many times already on reddit itself the
subject of the copyright claim is the
words that he used in his reddit
comments which had already been
discussed in detail
weeks prior to this point like i said
already the sources of information stems
from all the same places reading item
descriptions listening to dialogues
looking and interpreting the
environmental storytelling watching
youtube videos reading reddit all of it
that's how information gets naturally
spread around the community and how we
all can make theories on the lore of
elden ring and gaming overall which is
exactly what from software allows us to
do it's a big reason why they're
purposely vague in their storytelling so
the community can come together and
share information to come up with these
fun and entertaining theories on a game
we all love if and caligan thinks he's
the first person to come up with the
theory that the urgery feeds on struggle
shown by the corpses in the dungeons in
multiple pieces of dialogue then he's
delusional and doesn't understand the
community of souls games i had heard
that theory from so many other youtube
videos at this point and so has
everybody else you are not original
because none of us are all of this stuff
is from the creative genius of from
software
not us which brings me to the copyright
issues of this whole situation obviously
i filed a counter claim within an hour
of being notified that a caligan filed a
copyright claim on my video that day and
caligan finally joined my discord and
started answering my dms where he would
tell me that he still firmly believes i
read his comment word for word in my
video that youtube accepted the proof
that he provided which was just a link
to his comment on the thread and asks
why i would lie about it he also
mentions that my re-upload with the
apology did not credit him i told him
that youtube did not accept his proof
but that youtube under copyright law has
to accept any claim made by anyone who
at least fills out the copyright claim
correctly so that youtube can't be held
liable for the legal document that you
are now filling out and then i go on to
tell him that i didn't lie about it and
that i had heard the original theory
from practical meat not him he then goes
on to say that i read his comment
verbatim lied about it and it wasn't a
copyrighted theory but i took
copyrighted words he then links the
theory thread and the part of his
comment he believes i plagiarized he
then says that i plagiarized lied got
caught tried to hide it so he filed a
copyright claim and lawfully got my
video taken down i would like to take
the time here to go over how copyright
claims work on youtube and how and
caligan is misusing the system as a
whole and calgon told me that i should
read up on youtube copyright law because
any comments posted to social media
whether it be reddit twitter youtube etc
legally count as intellectual property
and you cannot just read them off and
claim them as your own words on top of
this he also sent me the link to
copyright.gov which goes over the basics
of united states copyright i'm actually
glad that he sent me this because it
clearly states what is not protected by
copyright which states that ideas
procedures methods systems processes
concepts principles or discoveries are
not protected by copyright it also
states that copyright does not protect
ideas concepts systems or methods of
doing something you may express your
ideas in writing or drawings and claim
copyright in your description but be
aware that copyright will not protect
the idea itself as revealed in your
written or artistic work which i don't
know about you
sounds a lot like the definition of a
theory i'd also like to bring up the
content section of the user agreement
all users of reddit accept when creating
an account which says by submitting user
content to reddit you grant us
royalty-free perpetual irrevocable
non-exclusive unrestricted worldwide
license to reproduce prepare derivative
works distribute copies perform or
publicly display your user content in
any medium and for any purpose including
commercial purposes and to authorize
others to do so so while none of what in
caligan is claiming is under copyright
it is not owned by him at all it's owned
by reddit on top of all of this i am
almost certain that in caligan has filed
a false copyright claim to my channel
i'm not going to show you his full email
for obvious reasons but i have never
seen a proper email end like this i
could be wrong on this but when i try to
email him letting him know that i'm
going to counterclaim him the email
didn't go through and was blocked so
either he blocked my email somehow
beforehand and just has some weird email
address or he didn't fill it out
correctly it also shows that he only
used his first name where i had to
legally use my full name when filling
out my counter claim this could be on
purpose it could be a mistake or i'm
just reaching here but if it turns out
to be false information that can be
considered perjury under united states
law i do think that's a stretch however
since youtube felt he filled out the
claim well enough to accept it there's
also youtube's fair use system where
even if i did take the entire elden ring
subreddit copy and pasted it as my own
read it word for word into my own 18
hour video where i added all my own
editing and sufficient originality in
the way that i expressed the ideas and
theories that it still wouldn't be
considered copyrighted i obviously
didn't do this and there's a quick point
that i'd like to bring up i originally
felt horrible that i didn't source where
i heard the original theory from i took
down the video i apologize i properly
cited where i heard the theory from
which is practical meat and re-uploaded
the video if i did copy and paste his
comment like he's suggesting why would i
go through all of that apologizing and
crediting the source
and not credit the comment itself
because i never saw his comment i
thought for the first few days that in
caligan v was practical meat i had read
this theory
weeks before making the video i
ethically felt bad for not citing my
source and i owned up to that right away
and tried to make it right and caligan v
does not want to believe that i didn't
plagiarize his work and he is entitled
to his own opinion on that but it still
doesn't warrant a copyright takedown of
my video and a copyright strike to my
channel filing a false copyright claim
is illegal i've been met by him in his
community on reddit with nothing but
hate and immediate takes on what i did
they don't know me but i know me and i
know i didn't plagiarize anybody's work
i was even responding to hate messages
from random people on all platforms in
hopes that they would know in caligan
and give me information on how i could
get in contact with him none of them
answered along with in caligan until
days after the entire situation and when
his reddit thread was taken down by
reddit moderators this is just my
opinion but i think he's just jealous
that a theory similar to his received
hundreds of thousands of views and he
isn't being seen as the winner he proved
that to me when he told me multiple
times that he needed to be public with
this entire situation instead of
discussing it with me in dms that shows
true intent to harass defame and spread
misinformation my hope for this video is
to show how people are misusing the
youtube copyright system and that it
likely needs to be looked at so that
people can't continue to do this to all
kinds of content creators on youtube a
lot of people have been comparing the
situation to the act man and quantum tv
drama that's been going on recently
while i don't think and caligan v is a
terrible person like quantum tv i do
think that he's misinformed about how
copyright works on youtube and just in
general especially when he's seeking
legal advice from the legal advice
subreddit what truly sucks about this
whole situation is that this is not how
the elden ring souls community should be
we should be constantly working together
to tell the story of a game we all
clearly love because video games have
[ __ ] sucked
over the last few years we are finally
given a gem like elden ring and i would
love to see the community be as good as
the game is that might be hard but it is
doable i am not making this video to
spread hate to anybody i just wanted to
give information on what's going on and
how these situations should be handled
honestly if i found out someone used my
entire video for themselves i would be
happy that hopefully more people are
getting the story that we are all trying
to tell that may be just me but that's
how i feel thank you guys for watching
the video i hope it shines light on a
situation that many youtubers are
dealing with right now also thank you to
so many people that showed support on
the updates i've been giving on this
situation hopefully youtube makes the
decision to reinstate the video and
remove the copyright strike on my
channel youtube could very well just say
they don't want to deal with this
situation and just leave it to the court
which is exactly what's happening
youtube has confirmed with me that they
have received my counter claim and have
sent it to the other party they have 10
days to provide evidence to youtube that
he's taking legal court action on the
situation if he does decide to take this
to court i am fully prepared to take the
proper measures for misuse of copyright
law and its systems provided by youtube
thanks again i'll see you guys soon take
care